hi there steve kaufman
um
today i want to talk about
language learning apps language learning
tools
the language learning environment that
we live in
uh remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
you know you can click on the bell to
get notifications
um
i've been learning languages since i
don't know i mean we had french at
school and i got particularly keen
as a 17 year old 18 year old in montreal
at mcgill university
ultimately went to france
studied chinese studied japanese or
learned it living in japan and have
learned a bunch of other languages
and that goes back over 50 years
never has it been easier to learn
languages
and part of the reason is because of the
the variety
of call them language apps
language tools
language services that are available to
us today and i'm only going to touch on
a few of them because i can't remember
them all
but let's just start with
you know
smartphones
i carry in my iphone
a language lab a range of audio
and text material
that would be the envy of any language
lab
50 20 30 40 years ago
the the range of material that i have
and if my phone gets
full
i can park them in my computer and get
them later so that that and i can listen
on my iphone i can do link on my ipod i
can read i can look things up i can go
to google translate on my iphone
or other dictionaries
and and i'm just touching the surface
because other people i mean the the
range of language apps that you can find
in the in the uh app store is is
enormous it's so many that you you don't
know which ones are going to be useful
many of them are not very useful
but i think the
the smartphone itself and of course
you know similar to the smartphone you
have the ipad which i tend to use more
for language learning especially if i'm
working on link
or
the ipod touch which i use when i go
jogging or when i you know don't want to
take my phone with me because it's too
heavy
basically
providing the same range of services
including you know studying on link
so that's to start with uh
mp3 technology of course has made it so
much easier to access audio than ever
before you don't have to go buy
cds you don't have open reel
tapes you don't have you know cassette
tapes you just have mp3 files which you
send back and forth to your friends
which you can find you can download you
can subscribe to podcasts there's
another
call it service the range of language
podcasts not only aimed at learners but
what i prefer to use is podcast aimed at
the native speaker on a variety of
subjects
you know youtube
youtube has
a great variety of
videos some aimed at the learner some
not
very often subtitles are provided in the
target language
with that i can import those into link
and study them as lessons so there's an
unlimited supply in certain languages
unfortunately
not in all languages and there are
issues for example learning a standard
arabic and there are very few
videos with
both the audio and the subtitles in
standard arabic so there's an issue
there but nevertheless there's so much
there that you can go to
now
in order to make sense of what i'm
listening to
whether it be podcasts or or even
netflix i shouldn't leave out netflix we
can download series there we can
download the dialog to link we can't
capture the audio but i can go through
the dialogue and learn the words and
phrases and of course their online
dictionaries become important online
dictionaries are extremely important to
link because in every language the
learner depending on their native
language can hook up with the language
with the dictionary of their choice
there are certain choice dictionaries
that are particularly useful
i am told that
jiso in japanese is particularly good i
don't study japanese so i have no way of
commenting other than apparently it's an
excellent dictionary which provides you
with stroke order for characters
different meanings different phrases
that use the words that you're looking
up
uh i find context reverso to be
tremendous gives you a range and this is
typical of what the online dictionaries
provide now is a range of phrases using
the word
very often they'll give you text to
speech
context reverso has a conjugating
dictionary and there are other
conjugating dictionaries so that if you
look up a word you can immediately see
the conjugation or it's not so common
for declensions unfortunately the
declensions being you know nouns and
adjectives which change form but for
verbs it's quite common to have the
ability to
to go and see sort of
the conjugation table
which i never try to remember but as i
look at it more often i get closer and
closer to a sense of how how that verb
works
remembering always that is going to be a
lot of exposure before it starts to
click in
but i mentioned text to speech there's a
tremendous resource text to speech if
i'm reading something in particular in
arabic
where it's hard to tell just how
something is pronounced text to speech
tells me how it's pronounced now i can't
listen to a whole lesson in
text-to-speech but i can listen to words
and phrases in text to speech i still
don't have text speech in persian which
is very unfortunate but we haven't been
able to find a text-to-speech service
that
you know
fits with the other servers that we
provide at
link uh google translate what a
tremendous service you know i i
have my uh
uh
you know my online sessions with tutors
and i struggle to say certain things and
even after i'm still struggling how do
you actually say that because the
phrasing is kind of mysterious and and
so i go to google translate and i type
it in in english i want to go i went
yesterday i should go anything that
you know has a verb form or tense or
mood or some structure that
i find difficult to get a hang of in the
language that i'm learning i just type
it in in english i get it in the target
language and so i often go to google
translate not only to look up the
meaning of a
word in the foreign language that i'm
learning but also to see how i would go
about saying something in that target
language so that's a tremendous app
i mentioned podcasts many podcasts
perhaps most don't have transcripts
without the transcript i'm kind of in
trouble because i depending on how far
along i am in the language i may only
understand 20 30 without the transcript
with the transcript i can import it into
link look up the words learn the words
but without the transcript it's very
difficult and it's frustrating to listen
to things over and over again that you
don't understand
so
automatic transcription services which i
mentioned before like happy transcribed
quite i mean remarkably accurate and
they're all getting more and more
accurate like all of these apps are
getting better and better i can remember
even with link when i was
you know i was taking three or four
seconds to look up a word
and and now it's it's instant and and
i don't want to talk too much about link
5.0 because
because mark tells me not to talk about
it because it's so complex because we
are we are
writing code not me but the people
within our team are writing code for the
ios system for android and for
the the web application and so there's
the
back end that has to be changed and
there's there's it just it's taking much
longer
than we expected but it is going to be
even better so
just as you know google translate was
much worse before right now google
translate which is also sort of machine
translation ai is remarkably accurate
uh automatic transcription is remarkably
accurate and all of these things are
only going to get better
similarly with link we think it's only
going to get better
again an indication of the world we live
in we have developers working on the
link project with my son mark i'm not
involved
from uh okay ukraine
korea
portugal
to in ghana
uh one in bolivia uh
we have uh you know customer service
people in serbia it's an absolute it's
an
international cooperative
venture
which is again an indication of the
world we live in where we are connecting
and because we can connect so easily
with people and i did mention i think i
mentioned italki there's another
wonderful application they have
such a wide range of tutors
with different price levels and
different skill sets and you can choose
the one you want
we also offer
tutoring at link but we don't have the
range of tutors that they have at italki
so you know and and there again i've
only touched on a few things there are
people who use an key memorize i don't
use those so i don't want to talk too
much about them because i'm not that
familiar with them
so this is the world we live in this is
the world we live in so that language
learning today
because of this abundance of of uh
wonderful functionality
that people are creating and and
six months from now there will be people
who will have created
other
um
you know
apps that help us learn languages
so whenever i hear people say well you
know with ai we won't need to learn
languages because we'll just be able to
talk at a machine and then the machine
will translate and the conversation will
go that way i don't believe it for a
minute i think the joy of communicating
face-to-face with someone in another
language the joy of discovering their
culture as i have been doing now talking
to my tutors in iran and discovering
that that one lives in
which is in uh
in
golistan in the north
it's all right i can't remember anymore
one lived in lahijan
gulon i think i can't remember see
that's the other thing you forget
everything but if i got into the
conversation i'd remember but so you're
connecting you're learning languages
you're connecting with people why would
people give that up just in order to
talk to a machine i don't see it
the language apps are making language
learning easier
and people are going to be more and more
successful
and so i see a very bright future for
language learning so thank you for
listening bye for now